the ukrainians are doing what they can
to defend solidar but this is what
they're up against ferocious firepower
and indiscriminate carpet bombing of the
town now in the path of the russian's
latest push in the donbass
this was a sanatorium once
now this is the constant background
it goes on
and on
[Music]
it's relentless now
[Music]
and there are thousands still trying to
live here
still trying to survive
their lives have mostly ground to a halt
they just exist
and prepare and wait for the next strike
which could come anytime and land
anywhere
the battle for the donbass is
desperately dirty
american officials have called it a real
gun fight smashing everything in between
people homes administrative centers like
this one in solidar but this used to be
his office
this is where you used to work the
advisor to the town's mayor like so many
just wants an end to all this
there's so much destruction being
wrought on this small town it's going to
take a lot of money a lot of time but
most of all peace to put it all back
together
this is what is left neela tells us
about her apartment block the constant
bombing is terrifying and many believe
it's remarkable they've survived this
long they speak of death and loss like
they're lucky not to have suffered more
mila's daughter was killed in mariupol
two months ago she couldn't even bury
her herself how old was she
valentina
just 28 and about to be married
[Music]
has been pummeled by bombs look at the
state of that kitchen
this is someone's home remember or it
was someone's home
and as the town was showered by
airstrikes over a number of days
this is the devastation
that it caused and imagine the terror as
this was all going on
of the residents are now underground
sheltering in an old soviet-built bunker
from russian attackers they once saw as
family
whoa okay
they're not sure how long they'll be
here
hi
but they've prepared for the long haul
diana is still holding on to her dreams
of being a singer
and cheers up the adults whilst the
bombs
is
it's a tick-tock tune she's learnt and
it's in russian
but it does the trick taking their minds
off the destruction and war which is
raging above their heads
the russians are advancing slowly but
they are advancing here in the donbass
others have come down to the shelter now
they've been three explosions whilst
we've been talking to the group already
below
they are somehow coping like anton they
have their battered homes just about but
they're fearful about just how much
longer as the russian army marches
closer
alex crawford sky news in solidar in the
donbass in eastern ukraine